I argued empathy is a a poor moral guide
it's biased to numerate it saps the
spirit it can be weaponized to make us
worse people but one question I often
get is what replaces it and in my book I
make a distinction between empathy and
compassion now a lot of people think the
terms mean the same thing and it's not
an argument word she could use whatever
words you want but psychologically there
are two different processes one is what
I've been calling empathy which is your
suffering I put myself in your shoes I
feel your pain and then there's all
sorts of effects most of them bad I
would argue but a second distinct
process is compassion where I care about
you I care about your welfare but I
don't necessarily feel your suffering
now you might say well just a verbal
difference so how do we know such a
compassion exists but there's some
really cool research exploring this and
actually I got into this because I was
at a conference in London and I bumped
into Matthew Lockhart
he was hard to miss a long Safran robes
beatific smile the happiest man on earth
and I got to talking to him and he asked
what I was up to and I told them that I
was against empathy and to me that's
felt kind of awkward by thoughts you
know telling a monkey against empathy
but he said Oh empty of course you
should be against empathy and he began
to tell me about his research and then I
I realized there's a body of research
neuroscience research that distinguishes
empathy some compassion exactly the
distinction I was looking for where they
put people in scanners and fMRI scanners
and they get them to engage in empathy
meditation where you you feel the
suffering of another person you imagine
feeling it and you compare that to
compassion meditation where you you care
for people loving kindness they call it
without an empathic connection in this
work which was done in collaboration to
neuroscientist Tanya singer illustrates
a real sharp difference where Embassy is
exhausting it is unpleasant it is
difficult
and it makes you withdraw
compassion is exhilarating it's
energizing it is seen as a positive
experience and it makes you approach it
makes you more likely to help and since
then there's been other researchers to
work by David to stand out of
Northwestern looking at the effects of
mindfulness meditation and a naturally
skeptical but that's work a lot of
claims what mindfulness meditation are
often overblown and I think we should be
cautious about them but destinos works
been replicated a few times and it seems
robust and the finding is it makes us
measure it makes us more compassionate
more kind for strangers and there's not
exactly consensus as to why this is so
but one speculation they have is it
makes us nicer because it dampens our
own tactic feelings less empathy more
compassion more kindness a lot of
relationships are based on on other
things and I actually think for many
relationships empathy gets in the way so
think about what you want from a doctor
or a therapist you you you want them to
understand you you want them to care
about you but you wanted to feel your
pain feel your suffering on the one hand
if they do so they'll be exhausted
they'll suffer from burnout if a
therapist sees a series of patients for
50 minutes each day and she feels their
depression their anxiety their fears our
anguish she wouldn't make it through a
week but wasn't that it would make them
less effective at what they do think
about what you want when you see a
doctor and you're very anxious you want
the doctor to be anxious know you want a
doctor to respect you to understand you
to listen to you to be concerned about
you but not to echo your anxiety or your
fear
certainly for a therapist if I go to see
my therapist and I'm deeply depressed I
don't want her to get deeply depressed
now we have two problems I have me and I
have her I want her to look at me that
therapist look and say so how does that
make you feel I want her to have some
distance from me so she could set
herself to solving my problems and to
providing a more realistic perspective
or take parenting
you might have a teenage son or teenage
daughter who's extremely anxious for
some reason maybe he or she left the
homework for the last minute and it's
freaking out a good parent does not
freak out along with their child a good
parent says okay calm down let's take a
minute we'll figure out what to do take
a breath and it's supportive and calm
and loving but doesn't inherit the
anxieties and suffering of their
children part of what it is to love
somebody is to is not to share their
suffering but try to make it go away now
it is complicated in intimate
relationships I think there is a place
for empathy often we want to share our
feelings and we want we want to share
the feelings with others sometimes in a
romantic relationship a couple one
person will feel angry or humiliated or
upset and wants their partner to feel
the same thing to share it sometimes if
you have a kid your kid is enthusiastic
about something
sharing the kids enthusiasm is important
I don't doubt that empathy plays some
such role but I think we tend to
overstate it I think when we think hard
about what other people need what it
takes to be a good person a good friend
a good parent what really matters is
understanding and compassion but empathy
often gets in the way in some way my
book is an optimistic book because I
argue about all of our our limitations
and how empathy leads us astray but in
order to make that argument we also have
to have an appreciation that we're smart
enough to realize that empathy could
lead us astray and that we're smart
enough to act those to override its
pernicious effects so it's empathy that
causes need a favor
somebody who looks like me over somebody
who does that or or somebody from my
country or ethnicity over a stranger but
it's rationality that leads me to say
hey that's not reasonable there's no
reason to do it it's not fair it's not
impartial and so we should try to
override embassy so what I argue is that
we have the capacity for rationality
reason this is actually fairly
controversial in my field my fellow
psychologists philosophers
neuroscientists often argue that we're
prisoners of emotions that was
fundamentally and profoundly irrational
and that reason plays very little role
in our everyday lives and a good one of
the main goals of my work is to argue
against that
now there's a specific argument that
authors often made which i think is just
not a good argument at all
which is to say well determinism of the
sort is true what we what we do how we
act how we think is the product of
events that have started a very long
time ago plus physical law we are just
kind of we are physical creatures we are
not we can't escape from causality so
we'll just continue doing what we're
doing and for the most part I actually
agree with that I think that notions are
more responsibility can be reconciled
with German ISM but I think determinism
is correct but none of that challenges
rationality and as an illustration you
could imagine a computer that's entirely
determined but is also entirely rational
you could imagine an another computer is
entirely determined but is capricious
and arbitrary and random and so even in
the deterministic universe the question
remains what sort of computer early are
we emotional creatures are rational
creatures but there is nothing not the
slightest bit of inconsistency between
the claim that we live in a determined
universe and that were rational
reasoning creatures
[Music]